hello and welcome to this video playing
against Canada master insane has
returned from Turkey it seems yes turkey
flag our Turkish flag so okay he's going
to play the Kings gambit so I'm taking
it go for the shallow defense which is a
good defense against a Kings gambit I'm
currently studying it not really
I'm not yet on a on a good level of
knowledge admittedly I'm still working
on that
we should ds3 okay so 96 I think it
looks fine Bishop d3 is actually quite
odd not sure what the bishop is doing on
that screen
let's see what he does I'm currently
already putting quite serious pressure
they're only five like you you might
want to cancel but what do you play
against he takes e5 maybe rook e1 or
something he takes a bit of time maybe
yabba-doo came in whenever he plays
we'll change the situation drastically
like if it was my move I was just
thinking maybe even Knight takes d4
could be an option Knight takes d4
Knight takes d4 Queen h4 check but it's
really not relevant because any move
that make sense for white would would
would change the situation so
drastically so sometimes this kind of
thought process like what would I play
if it is my move in order to kind of
better understand what the threats are
sometimes that makes no sense that here
is one of those kids because any white
move will change the situation a lot but
it's really weird is that he's not
playing okay so he castles ultimately
yeah D takes e5 looks like the normal
choice just one a.m. it's D takes ain't
it
luckily one man you will probably play
yeah I guess so
I mean Knight takes Queen d4 doesn't
work at all I think doesn't look like it
should work he has to put something on
the e-file Queen e1 Queen e2 rook e1
okay or something like that which is
just developing booth
so what to do I would like to get castle
of course maybe he is out for d5 in this
position I don't know
but after all I mean I really don't see
what's wrong was just taking this one
it's just a playable move and I'm now a
two pounds up or three it's three
already has three points so okay should
be seven cancelling next night on age
five is a little bit offside but he hit
covers f4 and this is some really funny
feature of this defense because you
think okay it cannot be great there but
it is keeping the pawn and it's not so
much about the material it's just that
you cannot develop with black you can
just cannot develop your pieces you know
in a meaningful way okay so I could take
on g5 here I'll just play g6 keep my
knight I think this is fine just keep
the noise
I mean Bishop takes a form I'm just
happily taking and then greps in 25 does
it work white really has to do something
crazy at you to at least get some
problems in the position something like
an OG four or something g4 F takes G 3
yeah or this one I mean the debt that
won't work
objectively speaking but I mean you're
down down ton of material so I cannot
take on pass all but I can go Knight f6
Bishop takes King g7 a that I should
really not work
you know the king is quite safe on g7
I've got a bit of time so let's not rush
it but this is good yeah he doesn't have
Bishop e5 or something like that and I'm
simply threatening to I was thinking to
take is he going for Bishop h6 yeah I
could take g4
this is actually not bad you know the
age file is if I can open it I'm getting
the attack going okay so I'll just take
this or with the bishop to develop make
sense to develop but it opens up the G
file
okay Jim 95 maybe and then take G 5 we
should have 5 doesn't work now I have 7
maybe that is a move rupees 6 okay if I
take their queen shakes okay get that
gets kind of it gets messy g6 is
attacked okay
ah shoot I did not see that when I did
keep losing this game this is crazy
not unbelievable stuff this is crazy I
mean what yeah I mean okay it's the kind
of game away everything like come on
this is this game say they drive me
sometimes crazy I mean like here this is
just not working at all I mean like no
way it works but okay yeah you got some
some lame threats and some of you you
overlooked something and then you get
made it no ok so King g7 this is this a
song like h5 should be strong yeah I can
take on can take on g4 with the noise
but yeah this is now we should be for
wins and I mean it's all a surprise it's
clear that black is completely winning
with night rookie 6 was was a bit of a
short and night f7 is also something
that I already mentioned that 95 is
really is a mistake just a mistake
yeah and this is for a practical point
of view not super easy because my rook
here is not yet playing and he's got
every single piece in the attack and
yeah I mean it's pretty clear that like
that there is a win for black but doing
it is a different matter and that 995 uh
oh it's night of cephalus is the more
problematic thing actually I think that
that I overlooked him so what was the
thing where did it get tricky maybe
really g5 it did it weakens g6 maybe
this is really the more they the easier
way to do it I mean it's not about like
proving like like wins this is clear but
you you have to like the thing is like
can you play in a way that in the
context of a blitz game I mean things
are easier to handle
yeah and that is maybe stronger sg6 is
not weakened and you always have this
night III idea which I thought about
this but then I felt ok why not why not
actually use them why not actually use
the age file and this is why I went for
the age 5 minutes which is it's +5 1/2
of like it's not like it's not like it's
bad it just makes it more difficult to
play and tear consorting with the night
but then you don't quite know why you
have played h5 so this is kind of yeah
and okay it's a the engine gives a white
all kinds of mistakes which is kind of
silly because what's lost anyway he has
to you have played four tricks which
worked so yeah and like Bishop b5 just
just make no sense
so what do I did what he had to do and
try try to play four tricks and and it
worked yes so after rupees six I'm still
winning with with with some moves yeah I
just I mean g6 was of course hanging
let's sell that doesn't win out that
because he can take away the Queen and
this is a strike this is - this is too
much so we have to gain Knight f6 just
go back of course the main thing is that
g6 is hanging I was just not really
seeing the immediate what I was thinking
is my idea was to return the Queen and I
thought I should win here which might be
true but it's not really relevant and I
am winning but it doesn't really matter
because he has booked g6 yeah then it's
always a bit annoying because I mean
white white played suicidal chess
already the Bishop b3 and Castle this
this is basically losing yeah you just
have a bad position with white and you
have to like sacrifice sacrifice to even
then get get some sort of sort of threat
on the road but really this is an
interesting moment and Nagi 4 is just
really it's just a lot easier to
because your king position is some sound
up yeah it's easier to convert and
you're not so much in danger of
blundering in a way yeah also assess
spend too much time at some points here
because at the end it really got very
hectic yeah okay that's interesting
thanks a lot for watching